today on Gareth learned things we're
gonna learn about blacksmithing I'm at
The Sword and the stone in ancient
Burbank California now this is where you
basically make swords and weapons and
armor and all that stuff for big grown
people or even your little guys like
this kid here let's do it
[Music]
what is the main thing you think I need
to know to be a blacksmith what am I
going to learn today that's going to
help me in my life as a blacksmith which
I think is going to happen after this
we're going to take a round bar of Steel
we're going to turn it into square we're
going to forge a blade on it we're going
to flatten out the other end we're going
to turn it into a bottle opener because
you know you've got to be able to open
your bottles of beer absolutely so would
you say the main the main thing I'll
learn today is Passion Fiery Path fire
yes yes look at me how does one become a
blacksmith in this day and age how does
that even happen in my case it was faded
I happened to be born in Hammersmith
England so I mean right off the bat
right off the bat probable yeah it was
kind of predetermined like you as a kid
you just had like the blacksmith Gene I
don't know I had an aptitude which I
realized a lot of people don't and we'll
see how you do I think you'll find
quickly I do not have the aptitude I
have the attitude right like I'll be
really like tough to deal with but the
aptitude I lack completely well I won't
get burned today and if I do you've
signed a waiver so I'm all good right
yeah right yeah right so and what is it
called again when you completely rip the
part of your finger off that's your
finger that's de-gloving degloving yeah
right okay well hopefully we don't
deglove anything and I definitely don't
want to be the penised
um I don't know if that would happen but
that ever happened no that's why you're
going to be wearing a leather apron
right yes right and a Cod piece right
I'm leaving here with a perfectly fine
penis but I do feel like
um I definitely have a good shot at
earning my keep today
yeah
[Music]
this is the forge the forge yeah I like
that okay so we're on the forge and
there's a lot going on here so when I
picture old-timey blacksmiths I picture
like a little tent is that
I mean this was it kind of like that I
do blacksmithing for Hollywood so this
is like everything else it has to be
fast right okay uh one thing I love
about it is I've done nothing and I'm
already filthy so it's it's ultimate
Hollywood because I've done nothing and
I should be thanked this is what we're
going to start off with so so it starts
here it starts this is this is a piece
of chromium Vanadium you know carbon
steel I thought it was chromium Vanadium
most things just as a dumb guy question
are you ready for it most things just
start out as just kind of a rod of metal
yeah or I can also a block of metal I
also smelt iron Sands and ore and create
my own metal or make pattern welded
steel like Damascus or incorporate
meteorites we're not doing that today
it's good because I don't think I
understood any of the things that you
just said degloving comes from when you
you're dealing with some and it the
glove is pulled ripped off of your hand
the skin is pulled the skin is fully
pulled off and then you go to the
hospital with the glove and you go hey
most of my fingers in there and they go
oh we'll take you to the skin Smith he's
over here and he's like hey let me get
that skin back on your finger I
didn't find the the piece of the finger
that I pulled off until two weeks later
sure it's still in my wallet but the
skin is still in your wallet can I see
what your mummified wallet skin looks
like I was going to feed this my
neighbor's dog because
can you blacksmith a bucket for me to be
illin so you can see there's you know
the full size
here and there's the mummified skin that
was in there
smell the Vanadium in that
okay so we move over to this machine
okay and let me get this out of the way
for you so we're not going to show you
500 pounds let's just move that out of
the way and then you know we'll scoop by
why don't you scoop by it or here and
then yeah you take yeah exactly yeah
we'll both kind of grab a piece exactly
and move it like that
no problem there easy peasy okay so
you're gonna take that
oh boy
what's happening Tony it's moving
not quite so hard not at this time I'll
use half my strength it happens a lot
where people say it's too strong Garrett
stop
[Music]
all right now we've got your bar ready
to heat up
good Lord
so yeah you could make a hot dog in
there
it goes pretty quick how hot is that
I don't know maybe six eight hundred
degrees right six to eight hundred
degrees Yeah
oh it's like a dog boner okay
all right all right now I'm hammering
you're hammering geez I do not know I
really thought this was going to be much
more hands-off not like a de-gloving
which is real hands-off
and and uh
it's not doing much but here let me give
it a go yeah okay there you go
even then we're not getting much
movement now but here uh what is this
achieved
not fair
[Music]
looks like a ton that was built for the
U.S Navy
in
1945.
Jesus Christ
[Laughter]
take that Nazis take that you Nazi sons
of well this machine weighs
about 7 500 pounds I have one coming in
next month that weighs uh about 16 000
pounds what is your plan with that
squish Hot Stuff take that Nazis you
sons of
look at that you're almost there wow
here right now but not just just because
it's Hollywood why don't we all right
Tony you can see that's pretty good but
I got that too well done I mean for you
know like less than an hour's work yeah
no I mean and you know I appreciate you
being next to me to Watch Over Me do it
but I still can't see the forest through
the trees necessarily on this then this
is gonna be a bottle opener too well
okay so what we've got okay
so we've got the the bar of Steel which
is still over here so we've taken that
we flattened one end of it sure that
flattened in will punch a hole in it
okay now we've formed this into a square
here right and then this end we've kind
of dropped in
and that'll be a blade okay then we'll
grind an edge so and what it'll be good
for is if like someone's making fun of
how I'm opening their bottle I can then
just stab them quite hot I will say that
things are falling off of it further yep
okay even further oh wow okay like that
okay okay now revised in take the take
the tongs off yep
okay and then you're gonna take this
all right so we're vicing in there oh
and giving a little twisty poo yeah is
that what you call it a twisty poop yeah
totally twisty can you believe that I
could Bend metal
just needs to be heated to 600 Degrees
and I can do it oh that's about 1500
right now but sure yeah math and keep
going keep going twist them all up okay
there we go
great more yeah yeah that's fine doesn't
matter I'm not tiring out so it's like I
could do this for a lot longer maybe one
more spin or so why don't you do one
just so the camera could see you working
yeah yeah exactly
yeah and this a lot it's like a jar of
pickles I kind of loosened the top for
him yeah and now he's sort of able to
spin it at that rate so you know I would
say probably six or seven times during
this process I thought I was done you
could have really I mean I don't know
what I'm going for so after this we go
to the degloving machine great I can't
I've always wanted to get my penis in
one of those
I'm gonna actually weld up this end
because it's a little
we over Twisted it when it was cold so
that needs to be welded yeah so that's
on me too
I'm a classic over twister they call me
the Chubby Checker of blacksmithing
do you feel it yep hold on
what that's all I did yep
exhausted
I'm pooped do you have a hammocker here
anything where you where do you nap
actually now that I'm thinking about it
I'd kind of rather have a can opener is
it too late to
make that switch you know what else we
could do this we'll do this it's fine
and there's your blade you forged
wow yes
I can't believe I'm gonna kill someone
with this one day
warning never put your fingers where you
wouldn't put your dick now I think
that's sort of what I was talking about
earlier when I was going to get deep
penised Okay so
so basically your policy here is
if you wouldn't want your dick near it
don't put your fingers near it
Jesus
ah a spark hit me Tony I'll be okay
it hit me on the side of my nostril but
I'm okay that's good you keep working
certainly wouldn't put my dick behind
your head I shouldn't have done that
how am I doing doing great okay thanks
Tony follow that bevel okay
we're a great team yeah
[Music]
I am sir Gareth of ancient Burbank with
my associate blacksmith Tony who did
most of the work honestly here's what I
learned today I learned that being a
blacksmith means you're going to be
around a lot of hot things also just
because you have a shitload of expensive
equipment does not mean your job is
going to be easy my shoulders are
killing me but the most important thing
I learned is that you can be de-gloved
which is where your skin can just fully
be ripped off your finger and then you
know if you're cool with it you can
carry that skin around in your wallet
like Tony here
[Music]